does your work have any implications for
what it means to have an identity so
right now you were talking about cancer
as if it's dissociating from the larger
cells yeah and then there are gap
junctions which you reference in your
other work and they effectively make an
equivalence class between signals that i
generate as a cell or my environment or
signals from connected cells i'm unable
to tell the difference between them yep
because i'm unable to tell the
difference between myself and my
neighbor it's as if i'm identified with
them so it has plenty of bearing at
least i see it has plenty of bearings
for what it means for the eye or the ego
in a non-pejorative manner
so what are the implications of your
work for the concept of identity
yeah yeah no you you put your finger
exactly on it so so so two two years ago
i wrote this paper called on the
boundary of the self and it's exactly
this idea it's the way to do to uh to
define what is a self at different
scales and uh how does the boundary the
size of that self change okay or over
time and that's exactly the kind of
thing that you that you're talking about
it's having having communication
channels that partially wipe the
metadata on information so that i no
longer know whether it came from you or
or whether it came from me right gives
us a partial mind melt because now it's
really hard to keep an identity if i
can't tell which are my memories and
which are your memories it's really hard
for us to keep uh to keep distinct
identities we become partially unified
and that's that's exactly the sort of
process that evolution exploits to build
larger cells out of small competent ones